Erica bernstead caught covid-19 back in
March 2020 forcing her to miss six
months of work
ever since she struggled to resume her
former life thanks to long-term symptoms
like headaches and fatigue long covets
robbed me pretty much of everything that
I love in my life my friendships my
hobbies my desire to travel my career
aspirations it's put literally breaks on
everything Beyond her own personal
health problems Erica's concern about
coronavirus makes her fear for other
people's futures I wouldn't say stay at
home and lock the doors and don't go
outside but just be aware that it's
there because the impact it has on your
life is is is forever lasting I don't
know if I'm ever gonna fully recover
from it for billions of people the World
Health Organization warnings about
covid-19 in early 2020 marked the start
of a new era it is
covid-19
an unprecedented pandemic that filled
hospitals killed millions and ravaged
economies
three years on and many Western nations
are notionally back to normal in cities
like London commuters no longer wear
medical masks and businesses have
stopped requesting proof of vaccination
but in countries like China a relaxation
of government restrictions in response
to public protests has seen mortality
rates rise once more
[Music]
Health experts say an end to the who's
emergency status particularly in places
where vaccines have yet to penetrate may
have serious consequences in other parts
of the world we could see with low
vaccination rates with weaker Health
Systems with fewer Healthcare
professionals that overall they're going
to be more deaths they're going to be
more complications and a larger disease
burden
as authorities continue to ease rules
once introduced to safeguard lives any
change in label may do little to combat
A continuing threat to life villain
marks Al Jazeera